les paysages l'horizon l'espace versé
sur sarthe a beaucoup pour plaire à ce
qui peut être plus que jamais ont grand
besoin d'une vie plus simple proche de
la nature et ses voisins mais ce village
d'à peine 600 âmes avaient du mal à
s'offrir un tenancier convenable pour
son petit café au coeur de la bourgade
il ya une quinzaine d'années lorsque
l'aubergiste 1 est parti la mairie a
racheté les murs de l'auberge est donc à
chercher des gérants qui puisse faire
vivre ce lieu et on a eu un certain
nombre de réponses à 2,2 des bois
percée s'est donc tourné vers un
programme porté par une association
active dans les secteurs social et
environnemental avec son programme dix
mille cafés l'organisation sos veut
rendre aux campagnes françaises un peu
de leur essence et de leurs âmes on ne
veut pas devenir un village dortoir donc
si on n'a pas de centre
d'attraction de centres de vie dans le
village et bien c'est ça qui nous pend
au nez entre alors en scène gwenaëlle et
son mari fils qui rêvait de vivre
autrement lui avait envie d'un petit
troquet dans un petit village
correctement le prénom tous ses clients
est vraiment que ce soit à taille
humaine et du coup quand on a commencé à
mener notre cher jean des petits
villages on savait pas trop où
s'adresser qui on avait besoin et on est
tombé sur la page mais café où ils
présentaient leur projet et là on a dit
qu'en fait c'est exactement ça qu'on
cherche
après quelques visites infructueuses
d'autres villages en quête d'un
tenancier de café le couple a été charmé
par percer sur sarthe parce qu'entre
village et petits commerçants c'est bien
de séduction dont on parle ouais ouais
non puis sont accueillants chaleureux
c'est pas comme avant c'était pas pareil
ce qu'on avait avant c'était différent
donc là il ya l'épicerie aussi avant
y'avait pas donc bon ben ça crée aussi
des liens on peut lui demander mathian
est ce que il n'ya pas ça elle va oui la
semaine prochaine ok je te prends ça
comme pomme ils sont ouverts à tous au
départ surtout quand on a ouvert en
janvier on ne faisait que épicerie donc
ça veut dire les fruits les légumes les
produits de dépannage mais aussi on fait
pas mal de produits petit producteur
c'est ce qui part souvent plus vraiment
les produits locaux ont fait au mondial
relay donc un relais colis ont fait
dépôt de pain pour une boulangerie qui à
côté 10 et malgré une ouverture en
pleine pandémie guen et fils ont su
développer une fidèle clientèle de
visiteurs assidus plus que des clients
ils sont devenus des amis sylvain roux
lyon est revenu s'installer dans sa
sarthe natale après avoir enchaîné
plusieurs contrats à l'étranger le café
c'est un peu chez lui des fois j'ai avec
mes enfants à des petits et des grands
on va voir quelqu'un de 90 ans qu en
train de boire un coup on va un petit
enfant 50 est en train de gambader et
tout le monde discute avec tout le monde
et je trouve que pour les enfants
ils ont une bonne image de ce qu'est une
personne âgées et pour les personnes
âgées ça leur coûte pas le lien social
ça leur donne quelque chose de dynamique
dette avec des enfants de croiser des
gens qui sont encore en activité de
choses comme ça et même plus de
manifestations qui se passe au sein de
l'église donc on est le seul point
vraiment
d'usinage point de vian médias un point
de vie que certains découvrent à peine
avec grand plaisir quand il ya plus de
petits commerces comme sérieux tous
comme ça c'est dommage mais j'ai
découvert ainsi aujourd'hui c'est super
c'est bien
j'aime bien au système de caisse tout ça
c'est génial génial d'accord mais est-ce
rentable sans l'investissement de base
offerts par le programme des 1000 café
le café du bout-du-pont n'aurait pas
ouvert ses portes wen et fils sont pour
l'instant salariés de l'organisation sos
mais ils espèrent que leur part ça je ne
sera pas que de quelques 16 ans c'est
pas forcément si c'est viable qu'un
projet d'arriver dans un petit village
comme ça 600 habitants donc ils mettent
un investissement de départ pour pouvoir
faire vivre ce café et puis au bout du
compte voire ou dupont si ça marche bien
que nous puisse racheter puis en faire
notre jeu deviennent tout le monde y
croit et puis voilà on a un rayon de
soleil et l'auberge et notre rayon de
soleil sur versées mais en plein hiver
ici marie-eve bédard radio canada a
versé sur sarthe